[Music]
have this sold on eBay place absolutely
that's my saliva hello no Spielberg
excuse me
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're out here in the desert
filming a big cold open for Conan we
have much things going on we have a
drone shot - drone shots
we have some cameras two really nice
cameras outfitted kind of it and it's
probably the best thing that's ever been
shot make sure that's on camera our
graphics guy Pierre came up with these
storyboards so if I see that I shoot the
storyboards taunton crossing the desert
with his little controlling carry-on
luggage I think I should look like I
write a man in a suit that's moved
across the desert specialist Ryan this
is Union Dirk disunion Dern is looking
down at that dirt we're gonna change up
mind a minute have this dry clean really
good job of interest we have to get this
shot done quickly because clouds are
rolling in in the desert
[Laughter]
[Music]
please do this tiny little border
crossing and getting harassed by the
Mexican authorities who don't want any
undesirables coming into Mexico any bad
operates
[Music]
he thinks he's in the clear but he's got
something in his carry-on luggage that
pisses everybody off Oh God
okay yeah that looks bad and the last
shot hopefully is is him just fleeing
into Mexico being chased by the Border
Patrol dog this is Roche he's the dog
that's gonna be in this shoot he's a
Belgian Shepherd Jairo
[Music]
what happens we use a real attack dog
for this shoot these antibacterial these
wetlands you know what I need it's just
a band-aid they don't have a band-aid
cuz that let me ran to get one what do
you have an anti werewolf venom uh what
if I turn into a Belgian what if I'm
interviewing someone sooner oh my God
thank you that kid came well I'm not
gonna say quickly the dog has since had
pups it's a dog it's a boy that's how
long it took for the kid to come thank
you Kramer someone you saved my life I
want to record sona's reaction to my a
medical emergency I wouldn't call it an
upward Belgian Shepherd jumped up his
club punctured my suit punctured my skin
two whole chunk out blood was coming out
of my leg I called for Sona Sona Sona
where are you
she's up here on which a nap were you go
you're playing candy crush
I don't play candy crush I play cookie
Jam my apologies
Belgian Shepherd wounds
my brain
losing consciousness
Kent is here to help us out with cue
cards he's also took nine shrooms
[Music]
are you high right now absolutely sound
like anyone shooting this I don't
good job everybody hey this has been
behind the scenes at the conan openings
new mexico show this is a wrap
i guess and you were behind the scenes
which is cool I guess
you